assez de morts sur les routes hôtels 2
vous invite à hisser le drapeau blanc
pendant le week-end de la toussaint
notre objectif sauver le maximum de vies
humaines contrôle technique obligatoire
pour les vieilles voitures permis à
points et paiement immédiat de certaines
amendes
ce sont les mesures décidées par le
conseil interministériel sur la sécurité
routière
le commerce extérieur va mieux 400
millions d'excédent le mois dernier
l'embellie économique se confirme
tdf un bientôt sur orbite si tout va
bien pour ariane lancement la nuit
prochaine d'un satellite contestées
intolérance et brutalité en france à
propos d'un film martin scorsese est
l'auteur de la tentation du christ
s'explique pour la première fois en
direct dans ce journal rapport record
pour le quarté de longchamp plus de 3
millions de francs pour 5 francs jouer
sur le 6 le 14 le 12 et le 11 madame
monsieur bonsoir après tant d'autres je
le répète vous prenez n'importe quoi un
vieux mouchoirs une serviette un chiffon
un drapeau à condition qu'il soit blanc
ou l'accrocha votre voiture n'importe où
à l'antenne aux rétroviseurs à une
portière
faites-le vous participerez ainsi à
l'opération qui pendant cinq jours va
mobiliser toute antenne 2 pour que la
route du week-end de la toussaint soit
moins sanglante dans un instant gérard
holtz vous en dira plus sur le
dispositif que nous avons mises en place
mais d'abord priorité aux mesures que
les pouvoirs publics vont nous imposer
pour améliorer la sécurité routière un
conseil interministériel s'est réuni à
cet effet ce matin dominique verdeilhan
première volonté du gouvernement
réprimer les récidivistes de la route la
route qui en france tu dis mille
personnes par an en 1992 sera effectif
le permis de conduire à points
déjà en vigueur dans de nombreux pays
européens toute infraction constatée
absence de ceinture excès de vitesse
feux rouges grillés ou conduite en état
d'ivresse entraînera le retrait d'un
certain nombre de points une fois ce
quota est puisée dans un délai de cinq
ans le contrevenant se verra dans
l'obligation de repasser son permis
autre mesure effective des 90
un contrôle technique périodique des
véhicules de plus de 5 ans un contrôle
qui devrait effectuer dans l'un des 4400
centre agréé une décision qui touche 16
millions de véhicules
la vétusté des voitures est à l'origine
de 5 % des accidents
deux mesures qui avec le paiement
immédiat des amendes dans plusieurs
départements pilotes soulignent la
volonté du gouvernement de transformer
les mentalités et comportements des
conducteurs 94 % des accidents
entraînant des problèmes graves sur
autrui soit des décès soit des blessures
graves sont le fait du comportement des
conducteurs il est donc normal que nous
travaillons pour sensibiliser les
conducteurs les avertir faire en sorte
qu'il y ait des sanctions là où c'est
nécessaire
enfin dernier soit du comité
interministériel mettre fin aux pistons
qui permet à certains de faire sauter
contraventions et amendes actuellement
26 % des procès verbaux face aux
oubliettes
ces mesures ont aussi pour but
d'harmoniser le système français avec ce
qui existe déjà dans d'autres pays
voisins et l'échéance 90 92 est une
manière de nous préparer au marché
unique le week-end le plus meurtrier de
l'année en france les statistiques de la
sécurité routière le prouve c'est bien
celui qui s'annonce avec le pont de la
toussaint
voilà pourquoi en collaboration avec
europe 45 journaux de la presse
quotidienne régionale et les assurances
générales de france
antenne 2 met en place pendant cinq
jours dispositif sans précédent gérard
holtz oui c'est vrai c'est la première
fois au monde
christine qu'une télévision qu'une radio
et que les partenaires comme ça
économique se mobilisent pour essayer de
sauver des vies humaines
alors vous le disiez tout à l'heure vous
avez raison le week-end de la toussaint
c'est le week-end le plus meurtrier de
l'année en 1983 par exemple daniel
leconte jean claude guillebaud qui sont
les producteurs de l'ensemble de
drapeaux blancs ont calculé on
retrouvait ces chiffres 3285 accident
209 tué 4985 blessés voilà notre jeu nos
chiffres tests et nous allons essayer
pendant le week-end 1988 qui correspond
exactement à ce week-end 1983 parce que
le mardi c'est le 1er novembre
donc nous sommes dans le même créneau eh
bien nous allons essayer de faire
baisser le nombre de tués sur les routes
comment avec 11 points directs en france
nous serons en liaison tous les jours
avec les journalistes et présentateurs
les reporters d'antenne 2 qui feront le
point donc sur la circulation routière
sur les reportages sur les témoignages
et puis surtout ce que nous voudrions
sur antenne 2 c et bien c'est
sensibiliser l'opinion s'est expliqué
très lucidement très sincèrement aux
français que les françaises sont de
mauvais conducteurs
il faut qu'on se leurrer fête ensemble
il y a des efforts à faire il faut moins
boire il faut aller moins vite et il
faut mettre sa ceinture de sécurité
il faut mettre aussi son casque
lorsqu'on fait de la moto l'association
des motards en colère ne le répétera
souvent il faut mettre son casque pour
éviter qu'il y ait des morts autant de
morts sur les routes et en particulier
pendant le week-end de la toussaint
alors le drapeau blanc ça veut dire je
respecte cette mini charte
ces trois points je mets un drapeau
blanc sans ma voiture voilà merci gérard
et des deux
dès 20 heures nous serons combien de
vies auront été épargnés grâce à ce
dispositif les ordinateurs de sécurité
routière le calculeront par rapport au
dernier week-end comparable donc celui
de 83
n'oubliez pas pour participer à cet
effort collectif il vous suffit de bien
conduire et d'accrocher un chiffon blanc
à votre voiture
changeons de couleurs et passant au vert
le commerce extérieur lourdement
déficitaire en nous accuse un excédent
en septembre 400 millions de francs en
données corrigées des variations
saisonnières contre un déficit de neuf
milliards en nous les importations ont
légèrement fléchi
les exportations ont fait un petit bond
en avant
un exemple à l'appui celui de ce
fabricant de blue jeans qui réussit à
exporter 90% de sa production en
allemagne fédérale
un exploit quand on sait que
l'habillement français 9 ans à
l'étranger qu'un tiers de sa production
en moyenne eve mettait
et
düsseldorf le grand salon international
de la mode
deux fois par an les commerçants
allemands au prêt-à-porter viennent
choisir ici les modèles qu'ils mettront
en vente dans leurs magasins
tee shirt orange cet homme qui parle
allemand couramment et français il sait
que le produit qu'ils fabriquent le jean
est un produit difficile
rien a priori de typiquement français
rien a priori pour réussir sur le marché
allemand où la concurrence est rude
alors il paie de sa personne trois à
quatre fois par mois ils seront rfa en
plus d'animer des stands dans les salons
ils visitent ses clients comme le seul
moyen selon lui de relancer
régulièrement les commandes
les fabricants français ont ici une
mauvaise image de marque difficile à
réhabiliter des fabricants français j'en
ai connus quand j'ai passé des commandes
je n'ai jamais reçu ma marchandise et je
n'ai jamais revu mon argent allait vers
le client ce principe
rené ehrlich l'appliquent non seulement
dans sa démarche commerciale mais aussi
en amont dès le stade de la fabrication
inutile selon lui d'arriver sur un
marché étranger persuadé que son produit
est le meilleur du monde
il faut savoir l'adapter j'ai dû le
modifier parce que l'allemand des bobos
plus grande plus forte
donc on a pu on a dû augmenter les
tailles les longueurs et autres il faut
s'adapter à chaque pays où c'est celle
que chaque personne a sa mentalité de
mentalité française mentalité allemande
italienne faut s'adapter aux gens
prochaine conquête pour les jeans foster
l'italie un autre marché où la
concurrence est vive dans l'habillement
mais rené un leash a appris l'italien et
il s'est rendu déjà à rome pour palffy
sa future clientèle
ce bon chiffre du commerce extérieur de
septembre revigore le franc et puis avec
les résultats encourageants de la lutte
contre le chômage c'est plus qu'une
embellie de notre économie c'est presque
un changement de tendance que devrait
confirmer bientôt l' enquête de l'insee
sur la conjoncture phillips à six wi fi
et si c'est un changement de tendance et
figurez vous qu'il faut remonter aux
années pompidou donc avant le premier
choc pétrolier de 1973 pour trouver une
météo économique aussi favorable michel
rocard
qu'est ce donc les dividendes de la
politique lancée par jacques delors 1983
est poursuivi par bérégovoy premières
manières et par edouard balladur avec en
prime il ya une forte demande mondiale à
laquelle la france paraît enfin mieux
répondre la semaine prochaine c'est vrai
il sait publiera une étude qui montre
qu'il n'ya pas embelli mais
véritablement changement de climat pour
notre économie la croissance trois et
demi pour cent cette année sera la plus
forte depuis douze ans et sans reprise
de l'inflation
les investissements vont probablement
faire un bond de plus de 8%
les entreprises redevienne prospère on
n'a cessé de détruire des emplois on a
recommencé à ancrer enfin si nous
important pour consommer et investir nos
exportations repartent
paradoxalement ces bons résultats vont
peut-être j'ai des gouvernements dans
ses discussions avec les salariés qui
savent selon la célèbre formule de
bergeron qui lie à davantage de grain à
moudre
mais notre situation reste fragile la
conjoncture mondiale notamment aux états
unis est incertaine avec plus de deux
millions et demi de chômeurs nous ne
sommes pas sortis de la crise et
pourquoi bérégovoy et roca donne rendez
vous aux salariés dans sept mois
reste à savoir si ces derniers auront la
patience testing d'attendre le nouveau
partage du gâteau
et justement quelques conflits sociaux
continuent de perturber la vie
quotidienne surtout dans les transports
en commun il n'y en a pas eu du tout
aujourd'hui à lyon ni à nantes quelques
débrayages aussi dans le métro parisien
et manifestation à paris des douaniers
salariés des transports cgt en moselle
plusieurs centaines de mineurs ont
occupé aujourd'hui la direction générale
des houillères du bassin de lorraine
par ailleurs nouveau préavis de grève
dans l'audiovisuel notamment à fr3 pour
le 4 novembre jour de l'examen du budget
de l'audiovisuel à l'assemblée les
infirmières ont à nouveau manifesté
aujourd'hui de façon moins massive que
les semaines précédentes notamment à
paris et en arles où le président
mitterrand rencontre est aujourd'hui le
président du conseil italien pour
examiner l'état de la coopération entre
la france et l'italie et les relations
est-ouest
les infirmières ont été dispersés par
les crs avant l'arrivée du chef de
l'état
à l'assemblée nationale le budget de la
justice n'a pas réussi son examen de
passage tous les groupes de l'opposition
et les communistes l'ont jugé mauvais
plutôt que de le voir rejeté le garde
des sceaux a dû utiliser la procédure de
la réserve
c'est la deuxième fois seulement dans
l'histoire de la vème république le vote
est donc reportée à la fin de la
discussion budgétaire
le rpr se dit satisfait de constater que
les socialistes n'ont pas réussi cette
fois à faire cause commune avec les
centristes et les communistes comme sur
d'autres budgets
charles millon udf nouveau président du
conseil régional rhône alpes une
élection sans surprise appuyé par
raymond barre et c'est une autre df
membres du parlement européen van
christiane scrivener qui va remplacer
claude cheysson à la commission de
bruxelles
elise est là tout à l'heure entre 3h17
et 4h13 demain matin si tout va bien
ariane s'élancera de kourou pour mettre
sur orbite le satellite français de
télédiffusion directe et des fins
l'épisode cruciale d'un feuilleton qui
n'est sans doute pas clos celui de
satellites cher démodé selon certains
est plutôt boudée par les clients
patrice pelé octobre 79
la france et l'allemagne décide de
réaliser un programme commun de
télévision directe dans l'esprit de ses
créateurs tdf a doit être ce que l'on
fait de mieux
la norme d'émission par exemple sera
européenne de plus elle sera puissante
pour être mieux capter image et son
stéréo devront être d'une qualité
exceptionnelle
les personne à l'époque ne sait encore
qu'il faudra attendre dix ans avant lens
étaient des f1 et qu'il coûtera 2
milliards cinq gouvernements successifs
planches consent succès sur des
problèmes techniques et financiers le
résultat
à l'heure actuelle sur les cinq canaux
disponibles cela 7 la chaîne européenne
à vocation culturelle a retenu sa place
trop cher on est conduit les autres qui
n'ont pris que des options à quelques
heures du lancement
la question se pose
encore fallait-il fabriqués et lancés
tdf un téléphone ne sera pas à gâcher cd
f1 est une belle réalisation
technologique et si le lancement il
réussit ce que je souhaite
cela nous permettra d'avoir 300 millions
de téléspectateurs en europe et dans le
maghreb atteint directement par ce
satellite cela nous permettra de toucher
un marché de 40 à 50 milliards de francs
pour les nouveaux téléviseurs à haute
définition
et cela nous permettra sur le plan
culturel d'être à l'avant-garde de la
télévision de demain
il faut maintenant espérer que tdf 1
arrivera en bol et en orbite et que le
lancement de son concurrent
luxembourgeois astra ne ruinera pas sa
carrière avant qu'elle n'ait commencé en
afrique du sud
interprétations contradictoires des
élections municipales d'hier pour le
régime c'est un succès même si quelques
30 % des noirs autorisés à voter pour la
première fois l'ont effectivement fait
pour monseigneur toutous et pour
l'opposition extraparlementaire ces
élections sont sans valeur puisque seuls
les noirs vivent autour des villes
blanches avaient été appelés au vote ou
un million de dollars des images
émouvantes tous les jours à la
télévision est une illustration lourde
de bons sentiments de la coopération
américano soviétique
les deux baleines prisonnière des glaces
en alaska ont été libérés et font route
vers le sud
tant mieux mais l'opération est peut
être moins innocente qu'il n'y paraît
comme nous l'expliquent de new york paul
nahon l'amérique suspendu depuis trois
semaines au souffle des baleines
enfin sauvé des glaces de l'alaska les
grands médias n'ont parlé que de
l'événement reléguant la campagne
électorale au second plan la vie des
trois c'est assez valait sans doute
mieux que les problèmes du déficit
extérieur de la drogue ou de la
criminalité mais qui a sauvé les
baleines le président reagan qui n'a pas
hésité un seul instant envoyé là bas la
garde nationale certaines mauvaises
langues affirment même que l'histoire
des mammifères marins a donné un sérieux
coup de pouce à george bush démontre en
effet que les républicains s'occuper eux
sérieusement d'écologie jusqu'au
soviétique venus aider les eskimos
américain gorbatchev a donc clairement
pris position
il soutient georges bush
c'est connu les soviétiques préfère la
continuité
enfin il n'y aura pas de suspense le 8
novembre prochain
l'alaska voté républicain en 1981 et
1984 le film est sorti en france il ya
tout juste un mois
18 salles devait le projet il n'y en a
plus qu'une la tentation du christ a
provoqué on le sait plus qu'une
polémique une vague d'indignation et
d'intolérance et aussi des actes de
violence une information judiciaire a
d'ailleurs été ouverte aujourd'hui après
l incendie du cinéma saint michel à
paris et sept jeunes gens arrêtés
l'autre jour sont visés la 2d reconnu sa
participation à l'attentât il est
inculpé et écroué ce soir jusqu'ici
l'auteur du film martin scorsese et
s'était refusé à toute explication
publique michel pascal l'a convaincu
martin scorsese et good evening bonsoir
les nuls alors la france est le seul
pays d'europe où votre film et suscité
tellement d'indignation et même de la
violence
est-ce que vous en êtes surpris tous
ceux qui ont participé à la réalisation
du film sont choqués de cette réaction
mais nous sommes en fait très attristé
parce qu'après tout c'est un film qui
est au fond très religieuse d'un film
sur jésus sur ses idées sur sa
philosophie qu est une idée d'amour de
passion de pardon et l'or ces actes de
violence et de brutalité sont absolument
gratuit dans ce contexte et je tiens ici
à remercier les directeurs de cinéma qui
ont accepté d'endurer ce genre de
des agissements quand même scandaleux et
ces incidents sont scandaleux alors je
vous propose d'écouter avec nous
l'explication que donne l'un des
cardinaux français les plus réputés
pourtant en d'autres occasions et sur
d'autres terrains pour son ouverture
d'esprit
il s'agit de monseigneur lustiger je
pense qu'il n'ya de liberté de création
que là où il y à véritablement respect
d'autrui car la liberté de tuer c'est
pas une liberté de création
la liberté d'insulter d'injurier c'est
pas la liberté de création
la liberté implique le respect d'autrui
le criminel pourrait se plaindre qu'on
ne respecte pas sa liberté
l'artiste véritable s'il ne cherche pas
d'abord le profit financier ou la
publicité doit avoir dans son coeur dans
son esprit le respect de ceux à qui il
parlait de ce dont ils parlent
martin scorsese et vous avez donc
entendue monseigneur lustiger votre
réaction à ce propos je trouve que
lorsqu'on voit ce film je ne sais pas si
lustiger a vu le film ou lu le livre il
s'agissait d'un cardinal moi je suis un
profane je ne suis pas un homme de
l'adie mais lorsqu'on voit ce fils et
même le comité de censure de royaume uni
a été mon avis c'est un film qui loin
d'être blasphématoire est un film qui
défend au contraire les valeurs
religieuses et aux contres est un film
qui assure une véritable promotion de
l'amour de jésus enfin c'est notre
sentiment au sujet de ce film
enfin ça ne m'étonne pas par ailleurs de
voir que ceux qui n'ont pas vu le film
réagissent de la sorte et c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui se passe également aux
états unis et c'est un malentendu est
épouvantable alors si l'on vous dit que
d'une certaine manière vous servez
d'alibi à une reconquête ou tentative de
reconquête de l'opinion française autour
des valeurs chrétiennes
est ce que vous en êtes contents ou
plutôt déchu en tant qu'auteur de cinéma
je ne suis pas vraiment déçu en tant que
réalisateur statines que je devais faire
faire petit budget ce n'est pas un film
destiné
à faire des gros bénéfices c'est un film
qui ne déçoit pas du tout dans son
ambition il s'agit ici d'avoir la place
sont nécessaires à faire ce film et
ouvrir les yeux un certain nombre de
gens faire découvrir des concepts sur la
divinité la nature dual divinité
humanité de l'homme qui était jésus
c'est une discussion un débat qui existe
depuis 2000 ans d'ailleurs et c'est
quelque chose qui doit être à nouveau
repensé et c'est pour ouvrir un débat
sur la question
martin scorsese et merci pour ces
explications c'est vrai que le débat
n'est pas clos il importe en tout cas
qu'il ait lieu sans intolérance et sans
brutalité
en chine ils sont 1 milliard et beaucoup
holt à vélo alors imaginez que dans
quelque temps ils découvrent une
invention viennent chez nous le
vélosolex non j'ai un cher à nos
souvenirs n'est plus fabriqué en france
malheureusement
mais il pourrait bien connaître une
deuxième vie ailleurs
nicolas jacobs et pour la deuxième fois
le céleste empire s'en trouvera
révolutionner un bon milliard de chinois
en solex de quoi redémarrer la longue
marche de cet engin mythique entamé en
46 est interrompue il ya deux mois la
chaîne de fabrication que vous voyez a
été démontée et son propriétaire la
société cf ps espère la vendre trois
pays sont prospectés la chine
l'indonésie et le pakistan
les chinois y réfléchisse sérieusement
le moteur en particulier les intéressent
économique
increvable il pourrait avoir d'autres
usages si la sphère se fait pour environ
2 millions de dollars cent mille soleils
seraient fabriqués chaque année pour le
marché chinois mais aussi pour
l'exportation par exemple vers la france
jean rien imaginé dans un film les
chinois envahir paris dans ce cas leur
cheval de troie pourrait être le
vélosolex de pékin le tennis à bercy
élimination du tchécoslovaque champion
olympique miroslav mecir battu par
l'américain brad gilbert qualification
de fric stein un autre américain et de
l'album hands of john mcenroe lui vient
de battre paul annacone en deux sets 6 3
6 2
vous êtes 3 veinards à avoir gagné ce
soir 3 millions 625 1662 francs en
jouant cinq francs dans le quartier qui
se courait à longchamp à l'arrivée le 6
le 14 le 12 et le 11 et dans le désordre
le rapport reste gros 44000 96 francs
c'est la deuxième fois en deux mois que
le kart est né passe ainsi la barre des
3 millions voilà dans un instant après
la météo de laurent cabrol drapeau blanc
sur antenne 2 le début de notre
opération sécurité sur les routes ce
sera le thème de l'édition spéciale de
claude sérillon à 22h20 merci d'avoir
suivi ce journal n'oubliez pas votre
chiffon blanc à demain 20h très bonne
soirée